ah
[Música]
en brasil hay 6 vacunas que han
alcanzado la fase 3 de experimentación
inicialmente la más prometedora era la
vacuna de la universidad de oxford que
de hecho se iba a probar aquí con hasta
5 mil voluntarios brasileños tras el
anuncio de los efectos colaterales los
ensayos de momento están bloqueados hay
otra vacuna que se llama coronaba que
desarrollada por una empresa china en
colaboración con el instituto butantán
de sampaolo que también suscita muchas
esperanzas en la comunidad científica la
razón por la que muchas farmacéuticas
internacionales vienen aquí para hacer
sus ensayos es que brasil ha sido líder
en el número de contagios en toda
américa latina y porque la curva sigue
alta una reciente encuesta muestra que 9
de 10 9 de cada 10 brasileños están
dispuestos a dejarse vacunar en cuanto
salga un producto aprobado por las
autoridades sanitarias sin embargo el
presidente y el bolsón haro ha dicho
recientemente que la vacuna no puede ser
obligatoria y que él no es un tirano
dejando aún más dudas en un tenso
panorama nacional
[Música]
en méxico de manera menos acelerada pero
constante avanzan 4 proyectos 100
mexicanos de vacuna contra el cob y 19
uno de ellos es el del instituto de
biotecnología de la universidad nacional
que trabaja en una vacuna recombinante
utilizando una de las proteínas del
virus sars con dos se encuentra en fase
preclínica de estudio con animales de
laboratorio y los resultados hasta ahora
han sido alentadores otros proyectos en
de la empresa avimex en conjunto con el
instituto mexicano del seguro social
esta empresa se vale de su amplia
experiencia en el desarrollo de fármacos
de uso veterinario y tendría la
capacidad de producir 20 millones de
dosis al mes sin embargo difícilmente
alguno de los cuatro proyectos tendría
este mismo año una vacuna ya que un
factor decisivo es la falta de
financiamiento pues si bien han recibido
los recursos aún hacen falta
aportaciones tanto públicas como
privadas para llevar a buen puerto de
estos proyectos
[Música]
aunque costa rica no se encuentra
actualmente desarrollando una vacuna
desde hace algunas semanas se prepara
para conseguir la primera que se halla
lista y disponible en el mundo
el presidente carlos alvarado dijo que
los planes son adquirirla en el primer
semestre de 2021 en este momento se
consideran acuerdos con casas
farmacéuticas y una alianza con el fondo
de acceso global para vacunas kobe 19
kóvacs una iniciativa de la organización
mundial de la salud costa rica entró en
contacto con las empresas farmacéuticas
astrazéneca de suecia sinovac de china y
faith de alemania en mayo de este año la
oms aceptó la idea del presidente
alvarado de crear el acceso mancomunado
a tecnología contra la cob y 19 una
iniciativa para el acceso libre de todos
los países miembros a un repositorio de
información relacionada a pruebas
medicamentos o vacunas mientras tanto
aquí en el país se espera con ansias los
resultados de la fase clínica de un
suero equino desarrollado por
científicos costarricenses este suero ya
está siendo probado en pacientes con
kobe y se espera probar su eficacia
el objetivo es que ayude a los pacientes
hospitalizados
a neutralizar el virus
[Música]